about an hour into the movie I hear not
just one of the children's voices who
are alone by the way I hear someone say
I look at the skinamarink 71 Rotten
Tomatoes now I'm like okay a real rating
a real [__] rating I can get by
something that stuff that's the best
that is the best rating you can get for
Rotten Tomatoes is 71 percent
in my
egotistical opinion
all right
but I look at the preview because I
still want to whip my appetite right I
see the 71 rating but I'm still like but
should I actually watch this
should I pay the three dollars for it of
course doesn't matter but
so click the preview I watched the
preview
I don't know what's going on the whole
time I watch it
the whole preview the two minute preview
I don't know what's going on the only
thing I know is that it looks creepy and
these kids like can't really find
anything that they're trying to look for
so I my um
friend is is over
our friend Kristen and I our friend and
she says
let's watch it
so I say really it's a real specific
watch you sure you want to watch it or
you want to watch something where we
could just like veg out and she says I
don't know it looks cool
so I say all right I turn it on I turn
it on
this movie's skin remembering
skinamarink
it's so very weird for 10 minutes
it's got It's like basically a slideshow
it's showing pictures some of them are
moving but most of them are not they're
still well they're moving pictures but
of still things it's like they're
filming the side of a wall
somebody's feet
the armrest of a couch
and nothing's really happening there's a
TV that's on in the background of a
cartoon with old-timey music which makes
it creepy and then every now and then
somebody says something but you don't
know who's saying it because it didn't
show any faces yet
and you don't really know what they're
saying because you can't really hear it
because it sounds like this
except for the fact that
sometimes there are subtitles and they
let you know what the person sings so
I'm like okay this is very interesting
and I'm watching it for 10 minutes and
I'm like hmm
but also
come on
what's going on here
make it a little more digestible
is this a movie
or is it ASMR
because the whole movie sounds like this
and while that's happening you'll hear
someone do this
foreign
now if you're alone in your car and it's
nighttime that was probably a little
creepy right
but that's what the movie is and I'm
watching it at night and my our friend
is there and thank God okay Kristen has
already went to bed right because she's
she's pregnant and she goes to sleep at
like 9 30 now and she's not Rihanna you
know I'm talking about
so I'm watching this with our friend and
20 minutes goes by
Haven't Seen A Face
still pretty much moving images of still
things sometimes a toy will come into
frame and like skip across the floor
where's boom
and it says where's mom on the thing
and I'm like all right look it is creepy
but but also
come on
make this a little more digestible all
right so
I look at our friend and I say
you want to keep watching this or what
and she says I don't know
so I'm getting no help from her I'm
getting no help from the [__] movie
I'm just like stuck it's 30 minutes into
this movie the movie's an hour and a
half and I'm so I start googling
I'm like I gotta Google to see if it's
so I Google
why is skinamarink so scary
and it comes up and now people I see
people saying
this is the scariest movie of all time
I see people saying I've never seen
anything scarier I see people saying
there are horror movies that's not what
this is this isn't scary this is
terrifying so I'm like what
so now I'm like all right I guess almost
I guess I'm along for the ride but I
better start seeing some faces or
something going on
foreign
a picture of like a tricycle and I'm
like all right
okay but I gotta I can't lie
if our friend left
I'm turning something else on
not because I'm bored
because I'm scared
South Park's gotta go on after that
because this looks like the devil filmed
this
there are no shots outside now so now I
notice in the movie all the doors and
the windows gone the house had doors and
windows then they're gone and now the
kids saying
I don't know if we they can't find their
dad where's their dad no clue so now
these kids are just in a room in their
house
watching they don't know where their dad
is they're alone and the TV won't turn
off
so I'm like that's a scary nightmare in
a way right it's like a nightmare in the
way of oh hey what was your nightmare
about not like this kind of nightmare
where you're like oh dude I was at War
and all of a sudden I realized I was
fighting werewolves and the werewolves
came and ate me and you're like oh I get
how scary that is it wasn't a nightmare
like that it was like one of those
nightmares where you're like dude I had
this crazy nightmare last night and
somebody's like what what was it about
and you say I was with like my grandma
or someone's grandma and it was my house
but the doors weren't there and my
grandma kept trying to like make me
pasta but she was in the other room and
I wasn't sure if that's really what she
was doing but then also there was like
this pile of bricks and I somehow had to
eat them but I couldn't cut them up so I
had to swallow them whole and you're
like oh well that's way worse than
fighting werewolves
and how long were you in the Dream well
they say dreams don't last more than
three minutes but I know I was in there
for 11 years oh
a [__] purgatory
I'd rather have werewolves eat me than
that right so so now I'm watching this
movie and I'm like this [__] is
really kind of creepy
I keep watching and
uh an hour in I [__] you not zero Faces
Sometimes you see these children's feet
you just see the a Lamppost or like a
foot of a bed
the TV's on the back
and I'm watching for an hour now I'm
like hooked I'm like okay well I gotta
ride this out and I look and they made
the move for fifteen thousand dollars
and opening weekend I made two million
dollars and I'm like what and then I'm
like oh the director
was a YouTube guy who would make short
films about people's nightmares and then
made this movie and now it's like got
some sort of awards and it's really
doing something and I'm like oh my God
so then
about an hour into the movie I hear not
just one of the children's voices who
are alone by the way I hear someone say
and on the screen it says put the knife
in your eye and I go
huh
well
I'm not sleeping tonight
because then you see the back of a kid
shake a little bit and you don't really
know what he's doing but then after
about a minute or two you realize oh
that kid probably put a knife through
his eye
foreign
by the way I'm not gonna ruin the movie
because you know why you can't
if I told you every single thing that
happened in this movie it wouldn't be
ruined in the movie because you can't
ruin the movie you can't spoil it
it's just terrifying
the movie ended
and
our friend
left
and then I was sitting there in the
kitchen and I said well I guess I gotta
go to sleep now
because I'm tired went to sleep
next to my wife fell asleep
woke up in the morning
forgot that I saw the movie
then when I remembered I saw the movie
I was
I had this emotional response with me
that was a very low grade kind of what
the [__] did I watch last night it was
all day then the next night my wife went
to bed early and I was downstairs alone
and I was too scared so I had to watch
[__] South Park this movie
Skidamarink is
it is one of the creepiest movies I've
ever seen in my life
and I am I really want to know what you
think of it I don't know if it's I guess
it's good because it made me feel very
very weird and it's very very scary for
zero reason okay and of course you know
me addict's Behavior I went on the guy's
YouTube page and I watched a lot of his
short films they're all absolutely
[__] terrifying so what the [__]
going on I have no idea but go see that
movie skin in my rank it's worth three
dollars to rent it
congratulations
[Music]